[Music]
my
do
[Music]
my
bye
[Music]
too so
do
[Music]
um
hey
good evening
hi
welcome to the table that was quite the
the intro i love that i can't wait to
see and hear more from our kids tonight
um i know yay you have to wait just a
couple minutes for that my name is karen
miner i'm part of the leadership team
here at the table
welcome welcome in here welcome to those
that are joining us online and to james
who's hosting our live stream so glad
that you are here tonight um i just have
a couple of announcements before we get
started with our kids and with worship
the first one is can anybody tell me
what tonight is
yes
it is sunday yeah good catch first
sunday is tonight the first sunday of
every month uh after the service we head
over to hat creek burger company in saxi
is just five minutes down the road and
we gather for a meal and some extended
hangout time so we would love for all of
you to be there once again it'll be
right after the service we'll go to hat
creek i think we have a couple people
headed out early dawn dawn is raising
his hand right here so when you get to
hat creek just look for dawn and he'll
show you where we will be sitting and we
would love to have you if money is an
issue please don't let that stop you
from going just come see me or any of us
that are up front and we will hook you
up with some dinner tonight we would be
happy to do that
secondly
we have had quite a few visitors
here at the table and every once in a
while we like to have a class called the
welcome to the table class just to help
new people or people that have been here
for a while but are just wanting to
connect a little further to know what
this church is all about
what our values are our mission our
vision and also a chance to get to know
you better as well so that will be
happening at the end of the month sunday
august 28th immediately after the
service and you are invited to come
we'll have we usually have a small like
pizza sandwiches something to tide you
over
during that time brett our pastor leads
that class
it's about 45 minutes an hour-ish and
has some great conversation
and we would love to have you be a part
of that if you are interested we have
visitor cards just outside the back door
to your right on a table just put your
name a way to get in contact with you
and just put wtt for welcome to the
table and we'll make sure to get you
more information and get you registered
for that it's
obviously it's free we're not making a
profit here
so without further ado
i would like to introduce brittany
johnson she's our children's director
brittany's wonderful
and i just i want to brag on brittany
sorry this is a surprise to her but
a couple of weeks ago it was national
ice cream day and
remember that brittany is so fun and
loves to do things with our kids she had
ice cream available for our kiddos and
um we also have some friends of the
table who were going through a really
hard time their their one of their kids
was diagnosed with cancer and so
aside from the ice cream britney and the
kids took time to make handmade notes
for the child her sibling which i
thought was super thoughtful because
everybody gets affected when something
like this happens and anyways i just
thought it was so thoughtful and so
sweet and and also fun with the ice
cream so that's the kind of person
britney is and that's who has your kids
um just their best in mind so brittany
i will let you take it for some special
stuff from our kids thank you
um okay first of all before i call these
crazy kids up
um
i just want to thank every volunteer
that was here friday and saturday
it was two very long days very two
exhausting days
a good exhaustion but very exhausting
and they all showed up and gave
everything they could
to all these kids
and i'm very grateful for that a special
shout out to our sound and tech guys
i was very hard on them and gave them a
hard time
and i shouldn't have been
but they were amazing and we couldn't
have
done it without them
um but i'm very i'm very grateful they
were there um also i don't know if y'all
saw it but there was a fun picture of
brett up there with an oreo on his
forehead just like on his knees and at
one point he did some beat boxing so
next year if you want to
witness all these wonderful things that
your pastor does you can fall into it
summer rama
it's lots of fun
um okay i have spent a lot of time and
energy on planning this weekend i mean
we started right after last year's with
what do we do better next year and
i love doing it it gives me life
but seeing these kids engage and learn
this weekend while having fun was
seriously one of the greatest gifts
oak came up to me on saturday and told
me thank you and i was like what he goes
thank you for doing all of this for all
this stuff that was so fun
and i looked around to see what adults
sent him to tell me thank you and there
was no one and i mean i could have just
melted right there in a puddle and then
the next day joe or last night joe told
me that zeke couldn't wait till next
year to volunteer and
i'm gonna try the crap
um
seeing him with all the little boys and
kind of just the natural leadership role
he stepped into was a gift too it's
really guys i love these kids and
getting to watch them grow up and grow
in christ and learn about his love and
who he's made them to be that was our
theme this year was that we are living
masterpieces um and it's just
i don't know i just love it it's i love
it and i love these kids so much um
so anyway
this weekend was an expression of that
love for me
and um
and i hope i mean i think they they felt
it and they loved it and we had a
special guest that came that showed up
because she heard about this summer rama
thing we were doing or in her words this
summer ramen thing we were doing at the
table
and she came in with all of these false
identities about herself she was a pro
basketball player she was a professional
dancer a famous youtuber
and by the end of the weekend she
realized she didn't need to be all those
things she didn't need to be all those
things for god to love her she didn't
need to be all those things for us to
love her she could be just who she was
and by the end of the weekend she was
able to confess that she was none of
those things and
um and we still loved her and she was a
little bit embarrassed about all that so
i really wanted her to come tonight but
she told me she wasn't ready so
i'm a little bit sad about that but
maybe someday she'll be here
there she is y'all she came
[Applause]
[Music]
she also brought her friends
or her siblings
chad austin and larry bob
[Applause]
molly i'm so glad you decided to come
and i'm hoping um
you'll do our dance with us later but
anyway
look at you so that's fine yeah oh you
had to come okay
i'm so yes but okay i have a question
because you told us you're not a pro
basketball player but you're still
wearing your jersey
well i also be learning that if you like
something you can be honest about what
you like and i still am still i'm still
so into basketball and i like this i
like i like this team
oh okay the jersey still okay but i'm
not i'm not pro
that
well since you're here could you tell us
like what was your thing that you took
away from this weekend what was what did
you love about this weekend
so hi my name is molly marsha mars you
can call me eminem that's what a lot of
people call me because it's easier to
say or just molly and so
i had never been to
church before
and yeah and so i was
looking on the google's was thinking
what's going on this weekend and sexy
and so i see online
this summer ramen thing at the table and
so i'm thinking i'm thinking guys
we're going to be having ramen noodles
at a big table and i thought well if
that's what church is about i like ramen
noodles and i like eating at tables so
i'm there so i show up and i'm here and
i thought the only way that i could make
friends well first of all is by bringing
my siblings so this is
chad this is larry bob
and this is austin so
yeah
yeah so i brought them with me
anyways i be i i thought if i want to
come away from this and i have all all
the friends and everyone likes me i'm
gonna have to tell them
some things about myself that weren't
true but i thought were super cool
and so
i that's who i
that's who i am and who i've become from
coming to
the the table church
and
and now i'm here tonight with a lot more
people
we are so glad you're here and we really
hope you come back from time to time
because there's a lot still for you to
engage and this is a wonderful community
to be a part of
okay kids y'all ready
i wanted to share one more thing
so
i wanted to share just one more thing i
thought she was gonna ask me about this
and then she it's okay
so
i learned a lot from um so many people
this weekend and i wanted to share that
because i thought if this is the message
and if some people in this room ain't be
knowing that message then i think i need
to tell you because i didn't know and i
was here so maybe you don't know but so
there's this god and took dust from the
ground dirt makes people right and then
you get to have faith this is what she
was telling me there's another one that
looks just like her
so that's confusing
you got sisters okay
so she tell me that you can have faith
that moves mountains but faith is not a
person even though faith can be a name
it's not always a name it's something
that you choose and that you do and when
you have faith it can't literally move
mountains like maybe you can but it
doesn't literally move the mountains but
it can move you to do big things and
if you are in
chains it's not literal chains like i'm
in i'm in jail no it's um it's symbolic
of something that's holding you back and
then what she told me she said she said
this she said this to me right here on
this stage she said uh molly do you
think pride's holding you back
and i was so offended
i thought that really cause i was like
no and then i went home and i'm googling
what's pride and i'm like oh my gosh yes
that's what that's what it's holding me
that's that's not true so i learned
about that and then i learned from my
friend zeke
is here
see
i learned from my friend zeke that we
asked this question we said what is most
what is the best thing god has created
and my answer was me and i meant it and
then it gets to zeke and he says family
and friends and i thought whoa
now that's cool and then i learned one
more thing from my friend phelan we said
what are some other names of god and she
says protector and i thought whoa a
protect not in video game irl you know
and so then one more thing i learned my
friend rex i don't know if he's here
tonight but
he's quite the artist and i just watched
him do his art and i thought that and
then we learned art can be worship
that is also like prayer and i watched
rex do um so i just wanted to share some
things that i learned and i'm so
thankful to learn it because i now know
that god loves me and loves my siblings
just as we are we don't have to be pro
basketball we don't have to have most
expensive shoes on
and but if you like it it's okay so
that's what i that's what i was learning
about
it's okay
are you guys
ready okay come on
come up spread out
you can go down the aisles you can go in
the back wherever you want to be just
spread out and make sure you're not
gonna
kick someone or
bump into somebody
[Music]
okay
oh
[Music]
out of these fathers
we'll take it out thank you marsha
molly
you guys are awesome you all can be
dismissed to your kids classrooms
thank you so much for sharing with us
i'm going to catch my breath for a
second
i didn't fully contemplate this
transition how i might be
out of breath when i got up here
for those of you who are visiting with
us tonight i'm mindy this is josh and
gary and jesse and we're so glad that
you guys are with us if y'all want to
stand we're going to do a couple songs
of worship together before our message
[Music]
god i just want to ask that you would
come and meet with us as we sing
together as we enter into this
communal activity
of speaking out truths of who you are
how we believe that you love us how we
believe that you are a good god
who is for us
and not just us god
but from the least to the greatest from
these little kids who come
and share the thing they're excited
about to the struggles that we face on a
daily basis
in our jobs in our homes
and our relationships god you are the
one over it all
you are the one that is carrying us the
current
that pulls us forward
we love you
be here with us
is a call tonight all the dead and
disappointed
the ones who feel like they are done
this is a word to all the ones who feel
forgotten that you
[Music]
alive and we're singing
alive alive
[Music]
your mercy's rising like the sun on the
horizon and we're coming
yes we're
coming home
[Music]
alive in you
alive and we're shaking
[Music]
you
this is a call to all the dead and
disappointment
the ones who feel like they are done
your mercy's
[Music]
i am set
free
i am set free
[Music]
me
set free
am set free
[Music]
shame and you could
you cover me with
[Music]
that i
am
[Music]
oh
that i am
yes lord we
are
grateful for
your grace and for
your love
yes lord we
are
grateful for
your grace
[Music]
yes lord we
are grateful for your grace
[Music]
set free
is
[Music]
we're going to enter into the prayer
of the people right now and um when we
get to the space and the prayer
that's open we just invite you guys to
speak out a name or a situation that you
might be carrying on your heart and if
you're online you can leave that in the
comments and we will share those with
everyone in the room
let's read this aloud together
for the city of saxi texas and every
city and community
and all of those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
so we lift these names and situations up
to you
[Music]
from online
for our teachers kids administrators and
school staff returning to school
[Music]
for these names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
so
jesus jesus
[Music]
jesus
to trust
[Music]
jesus jesus
precious jesus
oh
for grace
to trust him
[Music]
tis so
sweet to trust in jesus
just to
take
him at
his word
just to
rest
upon
his promise
and
to
[Music]
jesus jesus
jesus
[Music]
precious jesus
oh
for
grace
to
trust him
is god in all the areas
where we feel heavy where we are
carrying burdens tonight god i pray
that we would learn to trust you
i pray that we would find you
right beside us
studying our hand
directing our feet
resting our spirit
god as we take deep breaths
would we feel your lung your air filling
up our lungs god would we feel that
peace
that only comes from your spirit would
we feel that sense of presence that you
bring
where we know
it's going to be okay
[Music]
god that we know that you will be there
come let me we will find you with us
[Music]
god would you fill us
with your joy
with your peace
with your love tonight
[Music]
thank you for who you are and the way
that you love us
would we turn and love others that same
way
we look to you and we ask you to speak
to us and give us open ears that can
hear and a heart that can receive
and hands and feet that are ready to act
on your word
in jesus name
amen
thank you guys so much if you all want
to be seated and as you are you can turn
to the people around you welcome them
make them feel at home and brett is
going to get us started on our message
oh well good evening
grace and peace
it's um
it's really good to be back with you all
and uh just to welcome all of you that
as karen mentioned that also includes
those joining us online
uh thank you for being with us and uh
and especially um i mean all of you are
always welcome but
especially those of you who are new kind
of maybe making your way into the
community or just visiting um we're
really really glad that you're here and
some of you
may have i had to ask people if this is
their first time because i have not been
here in many a week i
took
scary
um
i took uh it sounded like a horror movie
um i took uh the month of july off and
then i had i got coveted like the week
before i was supposed to take a month
off so i preached but it was weird if
you were here i was up on the screens
doing like a live sermon in that way um
so it kind of feels i mean really at
least for me it feels like five weeks
since i've like been with you all um
and that's just part of my kind of
sabbath rest i take each summer so a
huge thank you to all of our leaders and
folks who stepped up in my absence and
just allowed me
to do that i'm so grateful
and
i also want to give a huge thank you to
brittany and her team
all that kid energy it was going uh i
think some of you may have been a little
overwhelmed like oh wow
um
it was a lot but it was beautiful i'm so
grateful for our kids um and just all
the volunteers and folks who were able
to
help us pull that off it was a great
great weekend
so um we are
coming back kind of to a series this
will be actually our last time in first
peter um that we're gonna do we'll do we
have four more weeks but um
it's first peter part four if you've
been with us for the last i don't know
it's been a while probably ten months we
kind of will like do some first peter
and then we'll jump out and like do
something different and we'll come back
and we'll leave again you know um and so
this is now our fourth time to revisit
and so we're in chapter five uh and it's
coming to the end of the book and it is
a beautiful ending indeed um tonight
we'll be touching on notions of
leadership um next week there's um
we get into uh topics there's uh like
anxiety um peace
um humility that's the message next week
is on humility and it's just it's a it's
a beautiful ending um to this to this
book so uh i hope you'll be able to to
join us for each of these messages
so the title of my message tonight is
turning leadership
upside down
turning leadership upside down and our
primary text is first peter chapter five
verses one through four
and peter writes these words he says uh
i exhort the elders among you
as a fellow elder so notice i mean this
is like the apostle peter but he's not
kind of coming down on them you know
like hey
i knew jesus personally so listen up you
know like no no he's like hey i'm
appealing to you i'm i'm i hopefully
churches you hopefully churches so i'm
gonna like connect with you know you can
see him he's already kind of doing the
thing that we'll get into um i appeal um
to you as a fellow elder and witness to
the sufferings of the anointed as well
as a communicant in other words like a
partaker in the glory that is about to
be revealed
shepherd god's flock among you so of
course is a metaphor for leadership
shepherd god's flock among you watching
over it
not under constraint
but willingly
in accord with god not from the sordid
desire for prophet but eagerly
not as
dominating
those allotted you
look into the world we'll get into this
there's a lot of leadership as
domination
as authority
you know
even having a pastor guild that word
might have given you some evgs you know
um
it is it's a huge huge issue in our
world in the church he says not as
dominated those a lot of you but
actually becoming models for the flock
instead and when the chief shepherd
appears that is of course jesus christ
you will receive the unfading crown of
glory
so um over my break i
wanted to not just read theology
so i read uh i read this book it was
great it was titled three ring circus by
jeff pearlman
and for those of you who are not into
sports ball forgive the sports
talk tonight i don't usually do this but
i am i do love all things sports fall
admittedly so
sports ball you say i just mean i love
all the sports um
so i read this book three ring circus
it's um it's about the three nba
championships won by the los angeles
lakers the basketball team uh in the
year 2000 2001 2002 this is when they
were led by i mean some famous people
this is uh we got a picture here of kobe
um shaquille o'neal
kobe bryant shaquille o'neal and their
coach phil jackson
and um it was it was a fascinating read
and i've got to be honest what stood out
to me
was
not
the uh stunning athleticism of kobe
bryant though he was
incredibly talented
um it was not the sheer power i mean you
see shaquille o'neal they're kind of
towering over the others i think phil
jackson in the middle is like 6 10.
so you can see
jack is over here you know um
so it wasn't the just sheer physical
presence of shaquille o'neal he was an
amazing player that's not what stood out
to me
it wasn't the coaching prowess of phil
jackson though he won if you're familiar
with you know basketball he won all the
nba championships with michael jordan as
the coach he went to the lakers and won
a boatload more you know none of that
stood out to me honestly i was
shocked at what stood out to me um
because
honestly i was i mean i don't even know
if i have um
language for it these are some of the
kind of descriptions i wrote down i said
i was shocked by the astounding
the astronomical
the
unbelievable
levels
of
ego
selfishness
backbiting
and utter
relational and emotional immaturity and
dysfunction
y'all it was insane they look like
friends there
they were not friends
not at all i mean so kobe comes in he's
like this is maybe when they won their
first championship maybe year two for
him so he came in as a rookie he's like
i'm gonna be like michael jordan i'm
gonna score all the points
so i'm not gonna pass
so he didn't like he would go whole
games
no past the basketball he just he got
the ball he's like one on one you know
he was just doing his thing then you
have now this of course made shaquille
o'neal upset
so he at first tried to reason with kobe
but kobe was very you know he wasn't a
listener i'll just put it that way so
jack gets upset at him refuses to talk
to him
so they for years
as they're winning the championships
four years did not speak not in the
games
not in practice
not in between now they would speak to
the media
about the and this was kind of the way
they weirdly communicated to get
messages to each other was using media
members to talk about each other now
then you think well phil jackson he's
the coach the kind of seasoned leader
you know
uh
honestly no
he shows up and he kind of gives up he
like at first tries and he's like oh my
gosh oh this is the worst i mean we're
talented
but this is the worst so he kind of
gives up then he resorts to passive
aggressive comments to the media about
shaquille o'neal and kobe bryant i mean
it's just
complete
utter
dysfunction so they did win three nba
championships honestly just because
they're so awesome
like just physically they're just
amazingly gifted athletes they just won
but
yeah they could have been dominant for
10 years
they could have been dominant for fifth
they probably could have won 10
championships in 15 years i mean they
were ridiculously gifted
so the strange thing is i'm reading this
book
and then i'm
reading first peter in preparation for
this message
and it was like as i read that text i
just read to you all from first peter it
was like the words were just jumping off
the page at me
because suddenly it was like i could
just see
with such um such clarity
the the problem the thing that these
amazingly gifted laker coaches and
players were bumping up against which
was basically um the problem was
themselves in essence that they're so
gifted but but here's the thing at the
end of the day
um they as the leaders and those you're
looking at the three leaders of the team
right there at the end of the day
they wanted it to be
about them
they wanted it to be about them
they wanted their legacy cemented not
the legacy of the team no
their actual their individual legacy
cemented and there's stories of um
kobe was honestly uh
notorious for this was he did mature
some in his later years and become a
little bit better teammate um
but in his early years oh he would like
like rookies he would make them carry
his uh well like everything like luggage
uh go get me water
you know go i mean it was like basically
it was sort of the opposite of first
peter chapter you know five
and it was like as i read i could just
see that at the end of the day the
challenge was that it was it was just
all about
them
um
it was all about the
it was all about them
and
this of course
um
becomes i think really honestly the
great it's the great temptation of of
leadership and power for all of us
because of course it's easy to look at
you know like
well honestly what do we kind of expect
when we give 19 year old professional
athletes you know millions of dollars in
fame and adulation and worship you know
honestly i don't know if i got to handle
it i'd be like yeah i'm not passing i'm
awesome you know like it's a lot
um
so my point isn't to just be oh how
could they you know but honestly it's to
say
um
this honestly this is our temptation
as you get just a little bit of you know
influence
get that promotion you know whatever it
is you just all of a sudden you're not
like the low person on you know the
totem pole so to speak but it's like now
you're kind of up there and you've got
some power and influence and suddenly
it just starts it's weird how it kind of
sneaks up on you and suddenly it's like
hey i paid my dues now it's time to be
about
me
and it's like amazing how we just slip
right into it mark chapter 10
um
verses 42 through 45 this is jesus
teaching that you'll you'll hear echoes
though of peter because basically peter
is just giving your he's giving you
teaching from jesus in his passage
mark 10 42 jesus called them together
and said you know that those who are
regarded as rulers of the gentiles
lord it over them
and their high officials exercise
authority over them not so with you
instead whoever wants to become great
among you must be your servant whoever
wants to be first
must be
the slave of all for even the son of man
did not come to be served but to serve
and to give his life as a ransom for
many
can you hear the difference there
um
you see what i think peter and really
and jesus are kind of laying down for us
is what we might call a a cruciform a
cross-like way of leadership
uh in other words we might sum it up
like this christians should not be
people who listen to a sermon about the
way of christ on sunday and then wake up
monday morning and imitate the
leadership style of lord rest his soul
see steve jobs
right who if you know any it's easy i
don't know if you don't know anything
about steve jobs he was i mean brilliant
yes gifted yes also a notoriously petty
arrogant and self-centered
uh leader
and often humiliated people under him
and it's interesting how it's so easy
for us to kind of come in here and be
like yes you know jesus
his way and then we kind of leave the
building
and it's like we just sort of start
falling into the ways of the world and
we start
you know venerating and lifting up as
models and examples of leadership the
people that the culture's lifting up but
we maybe don't realize is the way um
that those that that whole way of
leading is in contradiction to the way
of jesus
and um you know it's interesting that
the church um in the last i'd say 20 30
years has increasingly
begun to look um less and less to jesus
and kind of more outside the walls of
the church to the broader culture to
kind of get tips and tricks and models
and of um leadership
info styles of
leadership
and
really honestly looking mostly to the
business world you know and of course i
do think there were things to be gleaned
there i do think probably if you look
like now compared to 30 years ago
probably pastors tend to run like a
better staff meeting maybe than they did
30 years ago um but at the same time
what's kind of happened is that we've
started to
kind of take on leadership models and
mindsets
that
aren't necessarily the way of jesus
and that makes its way in this essence
what happens is sort of unwittingly
pastors and church leaders kind of
baptize
that
and then start living it out and the
problem becomes that the way it starts
to
impact
churches is you get you know churches
run and run more like businesses
and not in the good sense again not in
the sense of like hey things are
organized that's good you know that's
kind of a win you know to like oh good
we have things organized that's not bad
right um but i'm talking about that
leadership that mindset that things get
oh it gets squirrely
oh and i'll give you an example um
actually kind of two examples
there are two families i know of um one
of them i'm quite close to the other
sort of a friend of a friend um
but uh both of these families have had
someone um be diagnosed with cancer in
their like nuclear immediate family
um
and i'm gonna tell you kind of their
stories and how the organizations they
were a part of how it impacted them so
we'll call the first organization
organization a and this person was
an employee on staff there at this this
organization
and their wife was diagnosed with breast
cancer
and so their boss sat him down and said
oh my gosh you know like heart's
breaking for you you know we want to be
here for you um
but also remember
that you do you have a job to do
and we're just we're for honest we're a
little worried you know that with the
treatments and you having to take her to
the hospital and everything you know
that um you're going to kind of
slip you know your productivity is like
not going to be there and so we just
want to you know we love you we're there
for you but we also want to encourage
you um
to just make sure you say you know on
on top of things you know
um
now then there was organization b now
this family um totally different family
their daughter
was
diagnosed with uh cancer
and so this there's um a gentleman who's
the father and he his boss sat him down
as well
and said um hearts breaking for you oh
my gosh um we
i just want you to know that you take
the time you need
to get this figured out honestly you
need to be focused on your family in
this season
you know what we'll be fine
so truth be told if i don't see you for
a year
we'll figure it out just let me know
communicate but
you have a job when you come back
now the key question is which of these
was a church
yeah um so the trouble is of course me
we'd want to hope it would be
organization b because it's the way of
jesus and we're it's not just about the
bottom line and you know all the things
but i am sad to say actually um it was
so organization a was the church um and
organization b was a fire
uh station fire department
um
it was there i think the gentleman's
captain who sat him down and told him
that hey just take care of your family
you know um now what's
what's going on there what what's
happening
um
it's it's the way we start to drift from
the way of jesus without even realizing
we're drifting
we don't even know it's happening we
just we just think we're being good
stewards of our i don't know whatever we
think i won't try to psychologize about
what they were thinking um but we've
church we let's not lose our way
let's not lose our way let's not
proclaim jesus as lord here in this
space and sort of exit the doors and
it's like it's amazing how it just sort
of leaves our minds i'm right there with
you i'm not trying to put this on you
like i'm right there with you it's so
easy to just get out there in the world
and it's like hey look
i just gotta function just gotta do the
things i don't know we just it's amazing
how we just sort of let it go
and we don't we don't we just forget the
way of christ and and suddenly um we're
no longer taking our cues on what
leadership is on how to lead our
families how to lead our maybe
department at work or even a ministry
team here at the table
um
we're no longer taking our cues from
christ as to how we should actually walk
that out
now
um
what would it mean though like to take
our cues from christ let me let me
unpack that a little bit um here's how
i'd sum it up to think of myself as a
leader should be to think of myself as a
servant in other words as someone who
serves
um
in other words where we kind of have to
get to is the point where like right now
i think
when we tend to think of the word
leadership
you know if we've like played a little
word association game at the beginning
and he had a blank piece of paper and i
was like i say leadership
what comes to mind you know
and i think often it's you know i think
leadership it's like taking charge
you know making the decisions
um
calling the shots
you know like this is often what comes
to mind and it's it's strange though how
we often don't think you know service
you know i mean serving others like it's
sort of like no that's what and yet as a
christian
that's exactly what should be coming to
our mind now i'm
for many of you probably this notion of
servant leadership isn't necessarily
like completely new you know or like oh
i've never never heard the term the
phrase
probably many of you maybe not all but
many of you have probably heard that um
and
so what i want to do is kind of unpack
that a little bit like what would it
actually mean
you know servant what to be a servant
leader to take our cues
from christ on leadership okay
what does that mean though you know what
i mean um so let me let me try to unpack
this let me start with what i don't
think it is so i don't necessarily think
it's
it's kind of overly literal in the sense
of um to be a servant leader means that
the leader
literally does everything
you know like and then those they're
leading are sort of like sweet i am so
glad we practice servant leadership in
you know whether it's this family or
this company here this church or you
know it's awesome the leaders do
everything and we just you know we do
nothing um
no i don't think that's quite what it's
getting at instead i think um i think
it's more about mindset
um but i use the phrase earlier heart
posture the heart posture of christ
who
um well you can maybe think of it's like
the opposite of those early 2000 lakers
you know because for them it was like to
be the leader
basically means
you're here to serve me
you know i mean like that was the
mindset like you're here to make me look
good because i'm awesome and i'm the
leader and so you're all here to serve
me
but but what does servant leadership say
can you see how it turns our notions of
leadership upside down
to be a servant leader is to say
i
am here
for you
i am here for you
i am here to ensure that you grow
that you
thrive
flourish
i'm here to ensure that you're taken
care of that you're seen and empowered
you know your gifts
and then from that place
you feel secure enough to go
and serve
others
and that in turn what happens we begin
to create an entire culture
of servant leadership
can you see how that would change
everything
and it's remarkable because like here we
are 2 000 years after the birth of the
church it's like even as churches much
less trying to do this in the broader
culture even as churches we're still
trying to get it figured out
you know like we're still trying to
learn
how to do this well and i include the
table in that i'm not i don't think
we're exempt we're like still kind of
bumping into ourselves and trying to
figure out what does servant what does
this mean what does this look like but
i'll say i think we have to start here
getting our mindsets different
so it's it's not as the leader others
serve me no no it's as leader i serve
others now what i want to do in closing
the last few minutes is just return to
our passage and kind of unpack a few
principles like things that i think have
been sort of implicit so far let's make
them explicit based on first peter
chapter five let me give you three three
principles here um principle number one
servant leaders serve freely
verse two shepherd god's flock among you
watching over it not under constraint
but willingly
i think it's it's easy i'll speak to
just the church context for a moment i
think it's easy to serve to lead
from a sense of um guilt
you know like well if well god god might
be upset at me
if i don't do xyz you know and this is
where we kind of can shade into where
churches can start to get into spiritual
abuse kind of stuff because you know got
the god card you know and so that's like
a that's quite a heavy
that's like the ace you know it's a very
strong card to play and and so what
happens is you
it's just easy to um start serving
because of guilt because of maybe fear
depending on our image of god
um but peter doesn't play that card he's
like no no if you're gonna serve if
you're gonna lead do it from a place of
freedom not because someone's making you
not because someone's guilt-tripping you
but but freely
even when we have chose it though it's
it's amazing how quickly we forget that
we chose it i'm imagining sometimes as a
parent i feel a little bit victimized by
my children like who had all these kids
um
i mean it's amazing is it like even as
maybe a
business owner can become sort of put
out by their own employees that they
hired
you know uh or a pastor who's like um
frustrated by their own community it's
like what you signed up for this you
know so that's i think there's also the
freedom is sort of a double-edged sword
in the sense of it no one can make us
force it you know but on the other hand
it sort of puts it's weird when we get
into the whole the like call of god and
like i've even heard pastors use
language of life i'm just surrendering
to the call i mean i don't like it
but just gotta surrender you know it's
so weird like what no just quit if you
just need to resign that's okay you know
you're fine
um but we do this you know we get under
constraint we feel i gotta please you
know okay principle number two um
servant leaders have a mindset of giving
rather than receiving shepherd god's
flock among you peter writes not from
the sordid desire for profit i do think
he probably has like literal money in
mind there but of course the principal i
think is broader than that it's
what's profit we might sum it up like
this a servant leader is less focused on
what they're receiving
money
accolades position
power
less focused on what they're receiving
than what they're giving
that's the mindset shift
right and that's that's when everything
changes when it's no longer oh good
i can get that position and then i'll
get all of the good things do me you
know that's but instead when we start
living lives of how can i be of service
how can i love how can i serve how can i
empower others though everything changes
in that moment uh principle number three
servant leaders
don't dominate
they
model
peter writes not as dominating those
allotted you but becoming models for the
flock instead
i think one mark of a very antichrist
style of leadership i realize this is
strong but i really do do believe this a
mark of an antichrist style of
leadership
is is one where people or a person a
leader is leading from a place of
dominance
guilt manipulation and fear
that's the sign like that's when you
know like oh
and this is where it gets weird is i
don't care if it's coming from a church
leader
it's the it's the spirit of antichrist
it's everything against anti opposite of
the way of christ why because christ
came it's a symbol of the cross we got
two right here like it's it's it's i've
come
to lay down my life i've come to to give
i've come to serve and so you can see
now where
leadership in in a christian for a
christian i'll say that for a christian
becomes very different it's it's not
about dominating and forcing
it's about he uses the language of model
example
i think of this as um
maybe good metaphors like becoming an
aroma
like you know how when someone bakes a
pie
everyone starts finding their way to
where
the kitchen
you know what i mean like it's just sort
of like what's that that's nice can i
have some of that you know um i i wonder
if that's like our call
is to to be people of such great faith
hope love joy peace patience
that it's like it's just a beautiful
aroma and it just draws people towards
us we don't have to force and manipulate
and twist and
but instead we just model
we become
who we want others to become
and lo and behold
they follow
and they become it too
um
i think that's a beautiful beautiful um
model of leadership so as we come to the
table
of the lord tonight
may this be a moment where as as we take
in
the bread um
symbolizing the body of christ where we
take in
um
this wine symbolizing the blood of
christ
um
may it be a moment where where we
recognize what is it a symbol of it's
the christ the servant leader christ the
one who gave his life for us the one who
became a beautiful um aroma drawing us
to god and and so as we take it in may
it be a moment where we reflect on the
servant leadership of jesus and where we
are in turn
um challenged and called to live into
that
in our own
hearts minds and lives does that sound
good
so um instructions for how to
take communion
thank you um for how to take communion
are going to be on um
the screen sorry i got a fly attacking
me
um you know like he really cares about
his hair a lot he's kind of just
i keep okay let me come back to
communion um
so instructions are on the screen um you
guys can come go ahead and come forward
um
and
uh we practice what's called an open
table meaning if you're here tonight and
you want to participate you come forward
you say i don't know if i have all the
right theology you know that's okay
just if you want to connect with the
risen christ then then you're welcome to
um to participate we don't feel the need
to like defend
christ's table he's
it's fine everyone's welcome
um
so i want to uh just invite you to the
table with this this is a celtic
christian invitation
it says this um
this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
come you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the lord jesus himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
do
[Music]
i love that
we're going to close out with um
this song jesse's gonna lead it's
absolutely a beautiful song
um
but one of the things when brett was
talking it kind of reminded me of like
this
you know how sometimes you can hear a
message when you are growing up as a
child and even if the message was right
you have a way of kind of like
receiving it wrong you know what i mean
like later you're like oh i kind of
twisted that a bit
and i think there were some parts
of kind of the servant leadership thing
that
me growing up it almost meant like
instead of laying down your life it was
kind of like killing yourself
and kind of losing your identity or like
that would be selfish to take care of
yourself you know what i mean so it was
kind of like i had kind of twisted the
message a bit
um and what i love about the gospel is
that
when jesus calls us to lay down our life
that's when we find it you know like
the the more i let go of my ego the more
secure i feel and who he made me to be
and how much he loves us
you know and the more i
can settle
and not need to strive and prove and
all the things that get us turned around
um and so this song i i just love it
because it's kind of
reorienting us
or
our lives around jesus is our starting
place and he is for us
it's it's not
lose who you are because it's bad lay
down your life because it's selfish
to care about your life you know but
it's lay it down so that you can find it
so that you can realize that i i was the
beginning i was the source i was the
creator
i am doing a good work here
um so i hope you hear that theme
coming through and that it doesn't sound
like something juxtaposed against what
brett was just speaking but something
infusing it with more meaning and more
depth
jesse you can go ahead and get us
started whenever you're ready you guys
feel free to sit and soak it in if you
would like or sing it out
but i hope that it's meaningful for you
you saw me first
[Music]
it's the first time in so long i'm not
afraid
i'm not afraid
you are the voice that calms the storm
inside me castle walls to stand around
[Music]
you are the light that shines in every
tunnel there in the past you'll be there
tomorrow all my life your love was
breaking through
it's always been here
[Music]
it's always
oh i just wanna be right where you are
right where you are
you are the voice that calms the storm
inside me
castle walls that stand around me all
this time my guardian
[Music]
light was shines in every tunnel there
in the past to be there tomorrow all my
life your love was breaking through
it's always been here
[Music]
it's always
who stood with me in the fire
it was you
it was always you who pulled me out of
the water he was you it was always you
who carried me
[Music]
you are the voice that calms the storm
inside
[Music]
is
was breaking through
thank you so much for being with us
tonight here and those joining us online
um i hope something about the service
about the people in the atmosphere just
touched your heart tonight and helped
you to remember that you are not alone
um don't forget immediately after the
service we're gonna head over to hack
creek burger company for dinner and
hangout time it's over on 78 in
woodbridge like five minutes down the
road we would love to have everyone
there
also if you're visiting with us tonight
we would love a chance to connect with
you
this week if you wouldn't mind when you
go out the door to your right there's a
table they have visitor cards if you
could fill out your name and contact
information put it in the wooden box
that would be great that's also your way
to sign up for the welcome to the table
class so please make sure to do that
tonight before you leave
if you were comfortable and able to do
so would you stand to your feet i'd like
to send you out with this benediction
these words that i feel deep deep in my
soul are true for each and every one of
you
you are a child of god
are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these gifts of
grace and unconditional love
to everybody you come in contact with
this week
be blessed have a good night we hope to
see you at hat creek and we also hope to
see you back here next sunday good night
[Music]
you are the voice that calms the storm
inside me cast the walls to stand
[Music]
you are the light that shines in every
tunnel there in the past you'll be there
tomorrow
[Music]
it's always
it's always been you
it's always been
[Music]
[Applause]
you